we need to make prison smaller and safer
so that inmates uh not return to gangs
for protection
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with David skarbek
he teaches political economy at King's
College in London England and he's the
author of the great new book the social
order of the underworld how prison gangs
govern the American penal system David
thanks for joining us thanks talked a
little bit about how governance emerged
in prisons because this is a place where
you know the prisoners now they're not
going to get any help from the guards
and they have all sorts of reasons not
to interact with them there was in your
book you talk about the period before
the 1950s when prison gangs rose up what
was it like before prison gangs and then
why did the gangs emerge and how do they
govern things yeah one of the
fascinating things that my book looks at
is prior to the 1960s in California and
it turns out if you were incarcerated
during that time one of the most
important sources of safety or
regulation in your life would be not
gangs but something called the convict
code or the prisoners code and it was
just kind of a basic set of ideas about
what's acceptable behavior for inmates
don't lie don't steal don't you know
don't be incur debt and not pay it back
be a good neighbor to other people and
how was that enforced like if somebody
you know there's somebody contravenes of
what happened in a very decentralized
fashion so there wasn't an organized
monitor trying to find out when people
grow up these rules when the more that
people broke them the more likely they
were to be ostracized that would mean
that they wouldn't have access to
resources support from their peers would
mean that would more likely to be
victimized by other inmates and that
provided some pressure incentive for
inmates to kind of do what other inmates
hoped and expected and wanted them to do
okay and so then you know through the
50s and into the 60s that changes what
what drove the change and then what
happened the major changes the increase
in the prison population so for this
convict code to work effectively other
inmates have to know who you are and you
have to know who other inmates are but
as prisons get larger and larger the
prison population goes from fewer than
5,000 inmates up to 25,000 and
subsequently you know substantially more
there's more strangers around you and
that means that that ability for a
decentralized system to work works much
and and of course everybody is wearing
the same clothes so they you know you
can't you can't even really distinguish
people by you know most physical
appearances
that gives rise partly both to gangs who
then organize and racial gangs right
yeah absolutely so in the 1960s in
California there's dramatic increases in
inmate on inmate violence many more
stabbings and assaults and that reflects
the fact that the code is less effective
at providing the safety in order than
inmates one so what we see when we study
the history of gangs so prison gangs
like the Mexican Mafia the Aryan
Brotherhood and these notorious groups
when you look at their histories they
all form to provide protection and
security and safety to their own members
so in the 1960s and 70s they're forming
because as an alternative source of
governance to this convict code and as
populations increase increase
subsequently these gangs take on île
even more important and and one of the
reasons the race is important is because
again when you're everybody's dressed
the same that's one signifier where you
can guess ok if you're if you're white
and you see now the right guy they're on
the same team if you're black and black
you're in the same team Mexico what the
gang politics as they call it works is
it's a it's effective at doing what
inmates want because you don't have to
know a particular person you just have
to know which group they affiliate with
so that without a doubt there's there's
racist prison gang members I don't want
to deny that yeah but there's a logic to
it in that in an environment where Evan
wears the same clothes they have similar
haircuts they're in a roughly similar
age what's the easiest way to identify
what groups someone affiliates with well
the color of your skin is very low-cost
to identify and that makes that that
interaction between members of different
groups much easier to go it happens if
you you and you see this and shows like
Oz and whatnot or you know prison shows
if you're say you're white and the the
Aryan Nation gang comes along or
something and say hey you got to join us
what happens to the people who choose
not to yeah well I'm in California the
affiliation that you have to make isn't
typically with kind of the one of the
traditional prison gangs it's just with
a broader racial group the white inmates
may be from a certain geographic area as
long as you're willing to affiliate to
that limited extent then that's good
enough if you're not willing to do that
sometimes inmates affiliate with
religious groups or sports teams but
what's key to each of those groups is
that each member of the group is
responsible for every other
so when there's problems everyone knows
who to go to to try to control you talk
a little bit about tattoos as well
because this is you know it's a
flourishing industry or practice in
prison with rudimentary tools but why
how do tattoos function and one of the
prison is an environment where there's
lots of strangers around you you don't
know who's trustworthy who's dangerous
who has a good reputation and who has a
bad one tattoos are a way to provide
credible information they're permanent
they're often prominently placed so
you're not just going to get a tattoo on
your face your forehead indicating that
you have some past experience or
affiliation if you haven't because if
you did you couldn't very easily hide it
so it makes some great very credible
signals of information and in a world of
so many untrustworthy people and
strangers they're especially important
and this is they show up you know at the
at the hands above the neck etc right
because there's the whole idea I mean it
might be you know if we're we get drunk
and we go to a tattoo parlor we get one
on our butt that's the last place you
want to tattoo in prison right you want
it to be visible the more visible it is
the more information it provides to
strangers and the more the more easy it
is for other people to know what that
information is you're trying what was
driving the increase in the prison
population in the 50s and 60s well I
mean a variety of different factors the
big increase in the prison population
comes later in the 1970s and importantly
the 1980s and 90s and that's because
we're incarcerated people for longer
we're ramping up the drug war of fish
prosecutors are prosecuting more of the
cases that they're that erupted to them
so a variety of different factors all
contribute to this this big boom and as
you know I mean the United States locks
up more people than any country in the
world and that's driving or creating the
foundations for the importance of prison
gangs today yeah and and you say to
minimize prison gangs or the need for
prison gangs you you've got to minimize
the prison population prison gangs are
not ideal nobody wants these to be the
main source of order in prison they
don't practice accountability quality
rule of law anything like that so if we
want them to be less important we need
to make prisons smaller and safer so
that inmates on that return to gangs for
protection are you optimistic about
prison reform efforts going on now
particularly sentencing reform
some people like Rand Paul and a bunch
of other politicians really moving
forward it seems on sentencing it seems
that there is an interest and an
emphasis from from both sides from both
parties to support criminal justice
reform in ways that will reduce the
prison population one of the benefits of
doing so would be to undermine the power
of these gangs how did you get him
interested in in kind of studying this
issue I know your doctorates from George
Mason University talk a little bit about
the experience there and how that played
into this book well I mean the main
contractible interest is simply the fact
that the u.s. is an extreme outlier and
how many people it locks up and I think
that it's crucial that we understand
what is life like for those people but
the second kind of more broader or
academic point is to understand how do
people engage in social interactions how
do we in trade how do we interact with
other people when there's not a strong
effective government overseeing and
facilitating that interaction and
ironically in prison a place that has
lots of government action there's
actually a strong sphere of autonomy in
there so the goal is to understand in
instances where the state doesn't
provide the governance that inmates want
how does it how does it form how does it
look
what is the governance and life look
like in those situations and what can we
take what are the lessons that we learn
from there that we might apply elsewhere
but kind of a nice lesson is that even
for people who are kind of less educated
have less self-control are most likely
to get into trouble
even amongst them a very high level of
economic activity can take place the
downside however is that these are
people who are they can't exit they
can't leave the community they don't get
to choose who they interact with and
those are two powerful ways that people
develop cooperative relationships and
other settings and they're absent in the
inmate setting so I think really what it
shows is that those are especially
important and when we don't get those
the forms of governance that we have
aren't aren't some aren't something that
we can really get excited and thrilled
about I guess final question what is
what's your recommendation for a great
movie or yeah you know a great movie or
TV show that explores this dynamic yeah
well there's actually two great movies
that have made on this one is the
American me about loosely based on the
Mexican Mafia prison gang and southern
California and another film is a blood
and blood out
anyways both of those kind of capture
very well the prison gang element and
the informal element that exists in many
American prisons today well thank you so
much David skarbek of King's College
London the author of the social order of
the underworld how prison gangs govern
the American penal system David thank
you talk No thank you for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie